hogwarts legacy is being developed by
avalanche software
nope not the just cause devs the cars 3
devs in fact this will be the longest
avalanche has worked on a single title
given that cars 3 released all the way
back in 2017. avalanche has confirmed
the game will appear on pc ps4 ps5 xbox
one as well as the xbox series s and x
wb is publishing the game under the port
key games label which is a label
specifically created for the wizarding
world of harry potter we also know
they're using the unreal engine for the
project and although information has
been scarce since the initial trailer
warner media ceo jason keller tweeted
out four concept images back in april of
2021 which showed the house crests a
baby dragon a garden gnome and two grap
horns in a small enclosure on what
appear to be the hogwarts grounds also
one of the avalanche devs who works on
the sound design for the game did an
interview in may of 2021 where he
answered some questions about the game